and this piggy backs this rides right
into the question and we asked on the
show a lot which is do you think we're
in a simulation what difference does it
make
I do I do I think we're in a simulation
define a simulation if you really define
a sim you
absolutely were so we're in a simulation
right so none of what you see is
actually what you see none of what you
touch is actually what you touch we
don't touch anything you realize that
you've never touched anything in your
life the molecular forces
how can you touch one really the mass in
this skin I'm sure you understand that
so so the entire mass in your body is
probably a pin size and the rest is
space the rest is elect electrons
you know orbiting the nuclei and in a
you know at a very large distance and
the reason why you can touch is because
there is you know force here and force
there and they just cannot interact
right the if I really look at you it's
actually quite interesting I see you
inside of myself absolutely
so the reality is you do you're not here
you're mostly empty space
but the photons hitting your head are
just slightly smaller than the distance
is slightly bigger so they reflect right
so they reflect to my eye they trigger
an electrical signal that gets
translated into my brain as you know a
wonderful elegant shirt right but is
that really a shirt is that really
something is you know does a cat see it
the same way will the artificially
intelligent machines you see it the same
way of course not and so the reality is
that this entire world we live in is
just an electrical signal in your brain
which is not very different different
from halo yes just saying right it's
just but but it doesn't have to be a
video game it doesn't have to be a
simulation it just operates suspiciously
similar to a video game that there is
some grand designer of the game and that
there is maybe multiple grand designers
maybe you do have a controller and when
you get go through the portal of death
then you jump into controlling another
avatar and how many of your memories you
remember from your previous avatars who
knows this exciting stuff mo one last
question is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world what's
the only thing in the world the truth I
think the most beautiful thing in the
world is the truth and I tend to believe
that we're all here in a in a quest
that's never gonna be fulfilled to
constantly seek what that is which is a
quest that starts with finding out
what's not true
because in reality the only method you
can ever get to something that remotely
simulates the truth or represents the
truth is to at least find out what is it
okay and and my entire work as a matter
of fact even half of what I'm working on
now is that is an attempt to show you
how much of an illusion we live in and
believe to be true and if you just strip
the illusions one by one what's left
behind is the truth so it's a quest that
will take the rest of my life and I can
guarantee you I'm never gonna find it
but it's so interesting to just find out
what isn't one by one and when we truly
know the extent of our ignorance it's
easier to find out what's not the truth
yeah we are we're pretty ignorant we
know nothing at all
we know nothing at all true and we'll
help you here we will help you get to 1
billion happy and from there it'll be
easier to train the artificial general
intelligence I hope so yeah you guys
promised so you promise yeah we promised